I've objected for most of my life to the
whole pride thing and mainly on taste
grounds it has to be said I don't
begrudge anyone having a party I do
begrudge people mistaking their
sexuality for some massively important
signifier which demands that other
people then not just respect them but
pay them some special dues and actually
in actual fact you could see this so
that I've stumbled across Pride a couple
of times in my time I've never gone but
I've stumbled across it a few times and
one of the things that's on a simple
matter of Aesthetics a taste that I
deeply dislike
is seeing a bunch of of disco gays on
top of a bus waving to the public as if
they're celebrities sorry love you're
not a celebrity you're just gay that's
all and you shouldn't treat the general
public as your audience waiting for them
to celebrate the Magnificent wonderful
you so I think there's just this nasty
narcissism at the heart of this and I've
got no time for it